and this is what I love when everyone's
like oh I hate all this technology the
old days were better was it
you got your perspective there's this
whole notion of like breaking the fourth
wall Google and if you don't understand
it so many of you asked me so many
questions the answer is always Google
anyway you know what does he mean by
that you know what are the Joneses
Google that [ __ ] baby
if you can't Google stuff you're not
gonna be able to do anything that I'm
telling you to do um you know I think I
could do a better job of like breaking
my own fourth wall and explaining what
I'm doing in real time within it I'm
gonna go in scream live Irving it's that
because first of all you are in control
of so many reactions and so many people
dwell on [ __ ] that they can't control
instead of realizing they can control I
mean you could leave America for example
you could leave your wife your husband
you could change your job like you you
could stop talking to your mom you could
you know the reason it leads to
happiness is once you actually are in
the mindset of I'm in control you're
much happier because you don't feel like
some bigger thing is in control and you
feel helpless and like it's just it's
powerful stock you you need to start
recording sometimes when you put it down
because we could get some good [ __ ] are
you recording now do you rock just
missed the moment I'm so into the
flipped life right now I was like hey I
need a new camera I was like cool I was
just sitting here working I was like oh
[ __ ] let's both sign this camera and
[ __ ] sell it and then buy five
cameras and I'm not kidding I'm gonna
[ __ ] do that and guess what the
person that pays the premium for the
double Sun camera doesn't make a [ __ ]
fortune 11 years I'm gonna [ __ ] sell
it
flip life I'm all about it all right do
you rock what's this this is the camera
that we were using you and I and we're
gonna sell this on eBay you're gonna
sell this on eBay Seth and you are gonna
sell us an eBay and the plan is we're
taking this three four thousand dollar
2003
what is it four thousand our camera you
and I are gonna sign it and then we're
gonna put it on eBay and see what
happens
you're gonna tweet it out I'm gonna
retweet it I'm excited about this I can
sign it anywhere I'm so into this t
rocket I'm so pumped by you yo this is
so cool alright alright direct you're
gonna sign it - I'm in Orlando about to
go on stage there here we came down
yesterday we hung we hung out yep that's
that's the only way knows how to travel
yeah it's all over I ruined everything
that you know listen I have to make sure
that I win in the end of the only way I
know how I got a tip I'm sad the time
yeah as long as I can you possibly be
more hungry than me I think I figured it
all out you know tomorrow night late
tomorrow night so I'll see you I love
you dad it's my dad's big theory but but
he thinks that I've that I've got a
great master plan of like spoiling them
thus they could never be hungry enough
to defeat me exactly true and so you're
so secure you build onyx hack this
around here right - I'm so track of the
kindness it makes so much strength
the whole time and then it [ __ ] pop
out listen yourself please listen to
yourself listen yourself you coming out
with me yeah do you think probably
better I don't feel comfortable doing it
but you you know it regardless of how
much debt you have or responsibilities
or I have to feed my kids or put clothes
on backs or whatever your thing is debt
or responsibilities or most likely you
bought too much [ __ ] you didn't need and
now you have to work to pay for that
[ __ ] right because so many people I
love the people that buy a home that has
four extra rooms that they never [ __ ]
use and then they have to keep a job
that they [ __ ] hate to pay for a
house that has four bedrooms that they
never [ __ ] use I know my god facts
how many people here under 30 clap it up
for the youngsters all right under 30
under 30 you're not gonna believe this
but us old [ __ ] we lived most of our
childhood without the internet and it
was [ __ ] crazy let me tell you some
stories kids let me tell you how I tried
to use to meet up with my friends at the
mall you would talk during school and
he'd be like yo Ricky okay
4:30 at the fountain by [ __ ] Macy's
got it
now here's where [ __ ] got really [ __ ]
up and this is what I love when
everyone's like oh I hate all this
technology the old days were better was
it because I recall that when I go to
the mall and can't wait to Steve Rickey
to go play [ __ ] arcade games at the
mall but there was traffic or his mom
was late and I'd be at the fountain at
4:30 and after about 15 minutes I'd have
to give up and leave and then at the
next day at school he be like where like
by the fountain of Macy's like [ __ ] I
was by KB Toys
kids under 30 we should not find each
other we literally couldn't find each
other three-dimensional
thanks for being here you're the uncle
now to me it's time and talent the
reason I love hard work is its
controllable it's hard for me to be like
be more talented Gary you're it's
unhealthy
you can't garyvee you can't go to the
grave with all your money I'm like dude
I'm not talking about money and I don't
feel like it's working I love it
like maybe you don't like your job as
much like I don't think I can judge
anything I think the question becomes
what the next thing is to me it's like
to me what correctly correct but I also
think that people confuse it the vehicle
so the I think people don't often get
the right vehicle for their destination
you're right it's a vehicle now my
question is what's your destination
and if you told me it was down the
street I tell you to [ __ ] walk not
drive a Lamborghini so I don't think
it's an evil or it's wrong I think
people are confused to why they try to
unmask it and for what like how much do
you want to make it's arbitrary
what's at least not like we have to
unwind what's been pushed in our heads
you know 20 50 72 496 what to me it's to
me my big one is can I do what I want to
do every day I was doing that running
the liquor store and I was making fifty
seven I was happy as [ __ ] I'm no more
happy today than I was at 22 I was
pumped I was on a mission to build a
family business so big so that everybody
on earth would always say I did the
right thing by my parents in the way
they did to me I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it I really believe that I
really do I think when I watch people
that are driven by money I see a lot of
unhappiness and failure it's very common
I think I think the question is why what
do you need and do you have a sense of
that because by the way it evolves what
he needed at 24 is different than what
he needs now and him and me and that you
know so it evolves to if we did the
happy meter here it's the people that
are I promise you it's the people that
are doing what they want to be doing
like to me
yeah I couldn't explain to you enough
and I have a most empathy for the
cynicism around this statement it's
unbelievable how much I don't like money
I like the game
I love my game I love the game building
[ __ ] it's why building you know a legacy
is the best cuz it's like triple
compounding valuable right
I love the admiration I love the thrill
of the chase I wake up at 6 o'clock in
the morning the garage saleing because
there's nothing like pulling up
literally to this day I can't replicate
the high of going to a garage sale
walking into a yard of junk and finding
something for a dollar that I know I can
sell on eBay for 17 bucks is a bigger
happiness high than closing a 6 million
dollar account for Vayner and it's not
even close that's what I want for
everybody because that's how they get
the 20 I believe that I really do so I
think the fear I have with chasing money
is its short-term behavior and it leads
to a lot of like negativity even for the
people that achieve it the reason a lot
of people on Wall Street go into really
bad places in their late 30s and early
40s is the way they made their money
it's not something they're proud enough
about
that's why optimism or offense works you
know it does but I do think you need to
be thoughtful about the chasing the
money thing it will lead to a loss in
the macro I believe that I could be
wrong but that is my official point of
view and I've watched it way too much
cool thanks guys photos yeah awesome all
right book fan I know it's tough bro you
know you know what's even tougher
because of being are sports this movie
on in 20 on 20 on stage for the Q&A oh
[ __ ] yeah I forgot so if you want a
heart stop you don't have to be on there
what's uh what's my what's my stop on
the other end awesome
how are you was it about ten years ago I
said please sit Oh
a John I go I just started guy who is
your name like wine Gary buzzer yeah I
said you've got to be [ __ ] I want my
friends to join with me like omens in a
guilt factor I get it and nobody seems
to get that part they're like what are
you guilty about I'm like it's not fun
mate doing by yourself yeah it's the
same way yeah it's the best and now I'm
trying to transition I asset I do some
real estate still I do some other stuff
like that but I'm trying to find you
know detail what's the ticket for me
what's the next Joe what do you want I
can't like that party my employees if
I'm travelling I let him stay at home
working home I try to do everything that
nobody did for me that's right when I
was growing up right right but guess who
set it up leave guess whose fault it was
me brother you're preaching you know
this is what we're very similar oh no I
can years ago when I saw you I said this
dude speaks like me talks like me just
more articulate than I am I uh I believe
I cream I create a lot of entitlement a
lot I believe in it
is there hurt no cuz it feels so good to
give you know what I'm doing better now
is giving more context around it what I
used to do is here's a car payment when
an in say is like hey here's a car
payment this time and like and MD Rock
just so you know I'm gonna give you the
car payment this time next time we might
do something with Billy Joel that's ten
times bigger but I might want to take
all that money and invest it in the next
business so next time you might got
nothing right I didn't used to do that I
don't do that you can now like I said
you've got to create you just have to
over communicate yeah it's over now
follow mine me too you know why cuz
givers don't like to do that yeah
positive people don't like to do that
right yeah but you're taking some of the
energy out of the good yeah but what
starts happening is then I start
questioning why do I have this
satisfaction to make sure that that
you're good because it makes you feel
good makes me feel good too
that's a good thing ya know I've said
yeah don't let bad people tell you
that's a bad thing yeah look good people
think it's a good thing yeah like I
leave so much money on the table I don't
even want it I don't want to think about
how much
so do you find it you you lose focus
when you do that no I think shakes me a
little bit I want here's what's shaking
you not leaving the money on the table
the entitlement you're creating where
you've now created somebody thinking of
you negatively when you're doing all the
right things that's a good point so
what's happening brother so how do you
fight against it you start over
communicating you know I have employees
that hate me when I was [ __ ]
protecting them for a year and then when
they finally had to go and I didn't do
the right thing now I'm trying to
communicate more and I'm willing to take
a little bit more of the upfront
negativity because the way I was doing
it wasn't good enough right that's what
we're doing and it's not you just
employees it's even associates really
it's across the board okay life yeah
yeah that's true sister brother uncle
nice friends homies but I do get off on
it hang a lot me too I get a sense of
satisfaction that I can't create I'm
literally trying to become the nicest
most powerful person on earth cuz my
satisfaction the quench is so high right
but but you will crave entitlement so
understand that basically like sure and
and and continue to do things that
create more clarity for example I gave I
wrote a book called crush it then I
write Thank You economy I don't think
it's a coincidence in hindsight that the
book following the Thank You economy was
Jab Jab Jab right hook Thank You economy
was about giving at scale Jab Jab Jab
right hook was give give give and then
asked during Thank You economy in Jab
Jab Jab right hook when I would do I was
giving away at scale if I would do
anything like hey there's a new book
offer I have a new book out if I did it
like twice in a week
people are like you've changed Gary Vee
I'm like whoa I'm literally trying to
sell a thirteen dollar book you're
[ __ ] putting people on a pedestal
that are charging you eight thousand
dollars for a course but because they
created that expectation because I've
created this expectation so you know I
think you keep changing your game I used
to not say seven years ago I'm
comfortable selling as long as I believe
in what I'm selling I did that in
reaction to oh [ __ ] this isn't working
the way I want to but how did you scale
your
it's like my business from from a
service based business it's hard to
scale and when you're you know
vaynermedia is a service based business
I don't make I you know my business
right now my hundred fifty million
dollar business and with gallery my two
hundred million dollar business the
Vayner X business because I have media
part of it as well
publishing pure Wow and 137 p.m. it's a
service based business you have
something that runs it I run it who who
do I talk to every client no that
doesn't mean I have somebody running it
that means somebody is managing certain
accounts okay but in my situation oh
okay okay I would have a junior manager
basically that's what would have to
happen I would have to see you you're
not gonna be able to get out of this one
you know that because guy Oh Siri and
CIA and Morris thank you yeah I just
yeah you can run your I run my business
you can't manage every account so what
do you do you start changing it when you
sit down with Tina Turner you don't
paint a picture that you're gonna be the
only one ever you and decide you got
something good going for you you have a
huge advantage brother you're not driven
by money
which means when you take a junior you
or a junior eight honor that whole crew
or a d-roc who would be exactly the kind
of person who's a great human and you
walk in and go Tina and you give d-roc a
bonus of 20% on all net profit on Tina
he's running all for me and if he leaves
and steals Tina you're still good what's
the point that's the game that's your
game but that I have to get over the
that feeling of why why would you why
would you feel entitlement I do this and
why would you there's a why what's ready
for this for this security if I'm gonna
love it you're ready for this
you're it's your fault okay but how do I
get over that bye-bye communicating up
front a little more context back to the
first point set dude that's such a great
photo I'm well actually weirdly want
that usually don't want stuff as you
know
so what can you just can't help me can
you get it to the office somehow FedEx
or something you stay in Orlando for a
few days I'm leaving tomorrow
get inspired more often yeah what's his
name uh what's his name the person do
you know
Antonio I genuinely love you but I'm
telling you I'm literally through his
words I hate him flu his work oh good
it's so great it's so nice the way he
talks about you know I always think
about like the fun thing about
friendship is the best friends are the
ones that really talk the right way
about you when nobody's paying attention
the way he talks about you is like it's
really nice a real pleasure
how are you Joey
hi Carrie nice to Carrie I turn them on
to euros like you yeah yeah of course
you guys enjoy the talk
and it means the world showed about my
daughter here thank you back finger yeah
I hope so
[Music]
[Applause]
if somehow I could inject you with
perspective on how early you are in the
game at 45 it would change everything I
know you think you're late I know I know
you think you're late and I'm telling
you you're not like first of all thank
you back there mom first of all you're
just not like you know sure you could
get hit by a bus sure you could get
terminal illness but a substantial
chance that you're barely getting into
half time with the advancement of modern
medicine
everybody's got stuff but the biggest
the the thing that you're deploying
right now is a frantic speed that lacks
patience because you do think you're
late because you're looking back at how
you did it look at the way you
communicate it College and certainly
this and that that's cliche it's cliche
[ __ ] the way you sustain it is to slow
the [ __ ] down right the way you sustain
it is understand you're just starting I
wish you understand for all the good
that's happening in my life and all the
winning that people perceive that I have
I laugh when people are like think of it
that way cuz I genuinely think I'm just
starting you just have 20 30 40 50 years
of Arc or execution you just need to
slow it down and you can't make it about
arbitrary things like numbers thirty
five hundred forty seven hundred fifty
seven hundred sixty eight thousand it
doesn't matter what you need to do is
the right behavior that gets you to the
place that you want to and you need to
be able to sustain it and all you really
need is you know shelter above your head
clothes and a little food it's about
it's about what do you need and why do
you need it but the biggest thing is
slowing it down if I told you you
definitely would be happy as [ __ ] at 52
you take
you take it so I just think you have to
slow it down yo you know you know I'm
gonna make a audible here I'm in Orlando
my kids are in Disneyland like what
doesn't hear Oh what am i doing doing
these calls in a hotel room I'm gonna
dis I'm going to Disney and spending
time with them so
you know I love talking to fighters I
mean this both boxers and and mixed
martial arts fighters more than anybody
I've met out of anybody I've met
fighters understand strategy and
business more than anybody I know
they understand such subtle things
that's how I you know the the reason I
fell in love with boxing as a kid is you
know it's nickname was the sweet science
science I would watch fights on Friday
night fights on I'm older I'm 42 in
America there used to be I don't
remember if it was Monday or Tuesday on
USA Network's just fights
I would watch it's because even a
[ __ ] fight that wasn't hype I was so
intrigued by the chess of the fight yeah
you know it's what it's what it's what
I'm starting to get into with UFC
because I'm starting to understand
slowly but surely cuz I didn't
understand wrestling or jujitsu I
understand the boxing stuff there I
understand like somebody it looks like
it's gonna be a body punch the guy goes
two blocks it like Klitschko Klitschko
had a lot of knockouts because he was
very good at the subtlest thing it
looked like he was setting up a shot to
the body the guy you know what people
understand is how talented you guys are
how much film you know you know so it's
very smart it's I wish people knew
normal humans don't understand how smart
they see the brute it's so smart which
is why I love the counter move to the
move Klitschko knocked out a lot of
people because he had a way of tricking
people to make it look like he was going
to the body and he would go up he had a
lot of left hook knockouts cuz he was
very deceiving in the way that he set up
his body shot which then allowed him you
know and it was funny people would watch
and see the knockout I would have
respect for the guy that got knocked out
cuz I knew he was being smart to try to
Bach the you know I'm very fascinating
it's a it's a it's a phenomenal we said
we said interested that is the stuff but
unfortunately people that they cannot
transition each of your fighters
sometimes hard to transition this to the
business that's where court because
fighters especially already our usual
are employees you make your money by
making a percentage of what Dana White
does well thank you thank you man nice
meeting you
you want a photo yeah thank you brother
if I set to a 27 year old where do you
buy your art for your apartment there is
no answer that's the gap hey listen by
the way and I have no interest in doing
that to you and I want to support and
that's what I'm gonna talk it through do
you know what I mean how are you good my
pleasure nice to meet you
thanks for coming thank you responding
of course amazing seeing my pleasure
brother thank you so much let me give
your other one so I'll get a better
sister thank you you're welcome
[Music]
you're just like telling me a few days
before he's like can't be replied to my
tweet thanks for coming guys thank you
nice to meet you there Gary Gary thank
you brother
yeah I'm taking a photo yeah I forgot
let's go question yes well I mean it's
it's it's a lot of money and it's not a
lot of money
I wouldn't overthink what to do with it
do you know what I mean I probably
reinvest it in what you've been doing to
turn that five into probably like what
else you can do with it you know what I
mean
like you have a skill how much did it
cost you to get to that five thousand
put it into that hang this off real
quick sure love you guys back sorry take
care
thank you
hello hello so thank you everybody I'm
sorry I'm a little late
hi how are you hello how are you how are
you thanks for being here
how's it going guys get to know each
other you know to me the biggest theme
the biggest thing that is absolutely
true for this room is what I talked
about at the end which is for every
person here finance hip hop whatever it
may be
dentists it's very difficult not to get
excited about an under priced asset it's
why I [ __ ] with up-and-coming hip-hop
artists because when t grizzly and gonna
and young pinch and Russ and whoever
they may be are where they are two years
ago versus where they're gonna be in
three years that inevitably matters back
to like who knows how maybe I'm gonna
want gonna to perform at my daughter's
[ __ ] Bar Mitzvah you know like I don't
know but I know that under priced assets
is just always a good idea
I'm literally this is not a joke I'm
literally buying up hakeem olajuwon
rookie cards because I think Africa is
the next continent to blow up and in 40
years 40 years when Africa is on that
stage and Hakeem is the legend for the
number one global sport next to soccer
which will be basketball
I think Hakeem rookies at that I am now
buying for a hundred and ten dollars are
gonna be worth four thousand
what's that I'm by Barclays because I
think he'll be culturally relevant and
panini just signed him to a deal and I
think he's going to be in the zeitgeist
over the next three to five years and I
just and I enjoy that [ __ ] like I enjoy
trading emerging hip-hop artists I enjoy
trading social media platforms wine
people who have just all the same kind
of one big macro game of like are you
right about what the world's gonna do
it's why I am so bullish on China China
agrees with me on Africa which is why
they bought up all of Africa China the
countries playing bigger than I am I'm
buying a team rookies they're buying the
country but you know the continent
excuse me
but uh they made an unbelievably
infrastructure investment so
so that's why I think to your point
whatever you feel the content in your
Instagram or Facebook it you know you'll
have to decide based on your ambitions
and wants short-term and long-term but
the buy is right it's real estate like
if I told you Malibu was gonna be Malibu
49 years ago you would buy beachfront
property would you need to build a
beautiful house at that moment because
you still lived in Florida probably not
you might have not done anything with it
but you would have bought the property
there's a belief that I have on these
platforms that you should buy the
property you can you can build a house
on Finance and then you could tear it
down in nine years and build it around
watches because that's your passion got
it
I believe you can be many things as long
as they're your true things I believe
that Will Smith can be Will Smith after
he was the French Prince I believe that
Mark Wahlberg can be Mark Wahlberg after
he was Marky Mark I believe there so you
know what I mean
I believe that Dwayne Johnson to be
doing John these are moguls that started
off as not they're the passion to drive
the ambition the creativity the energy
and they had the ability to have the
humility to do what they had to do and
they had the intention to pivot and if
they execute it against the attention
they win that's what I do
I was the wine guy you know like like if
you can execute against the attention if
you understand where the attention is
you can do very big things [ __ ] 80% of
that audience 90% of that audience would
die to make a hundred thousand years and
and it scares me let me say it like that
is the word I want to use it scares me
how easy it is with enough education
humility you have that the humility to
go to the goodwill to go to a flea
market to go to a Best Buy and load up a
truck like people like people don't like
to be judged and when I go to the real
bottom you know like because I win and
hip hop in other places I got fans are
like in it in it like where $50 matters
we're like they're like yo I robbed
three people today like I don't want to
do this no more Gary Vee helped me like
[ __ ] that we will not talk about today
and I'm like okay go to Craigslist go
pick up [ __ ] for the amount of people
were like just random tweets like holy
[ __ ] this is real I made two hundred
eight dollars in the last four days and
it matters and I you know I was so
fortunate that I've lived a life where I
lived a life where a hundred dollars
meant a hell of a lot more like I know
where I thought a hundred dollars meant
more to me than what a million dollar
you know like you know it and you could
taste it and you can only taste my kids
will never know that nothing they're bad
or wrong or sock or entitled they just
will never know I
no nothing feels like the email or DM I
get there like Gary me
I made eighty one dollars because I went
to [ __ ] Goodwill today and sold on
Facebook and that's gonna buy dinner
this week for my family that [ __ ] [ __ ]
with me emotionally like you would not
believe
[Music]
[Music]